well it looks like no one watched this
movie this past weekend but I watched it
I want to talk about it hopefully you
guys give a to hear me talk about
it here we go
a monster calls so a monster calls is a
movie among the top 10 highest grossing
movies its opening weekend this past
weekend came in 13 yeah I told you no
one watched those the movie revolves
around a kid named Connor who has a lot
of turmoil in his life his mom is really
sick his dad is nowhere to be seen
bullies pick on him at school so one day
this tree comes to life is voiced by
Liam Neeson the trees like I'm gonna
tell you some stories counters like what
you're gonna tell me what that's eight
is what you're gonna do I gotta lie I
kind of thought that too but then the
tree starts telling stories to this kid
these stories are applicable to his life
his interpretation of what's going on in
his inner turmoil in the movie really
all comes together and it gives you a
pretty good time first of all the kid in
this movie is a good actor and that's
always you're like whoa what kids the
main star but it totally worked out for
this one also I like the tree not only
for the fact that is voiced by Liam
Neeson which makes the tree an instant
badass so when the tree lays out his
story you have your thoughts on it and
then the tree gives you this other angle
to look at you're like yeah but ya
didn't see it that way I mean you see
the stories as the kid sees the stories
and then Liam Neeson's trees like uh or
or this Felicity Jones was great too
it's a it's like I see Felicity Jones is
acting and range for what it is and if
she plays up what it is is she's
fantastic in it it's great for dramas
like this I could never see Felicity
Jones being in a comedy maybe she just
hasn't shown that side of her I don't
know I just I've never seen it so I
can't actually quantify that but
Felicity Jones was just heartbreakingly
good as the mom who wants to be there
for her kid really the only anchor this
kid has in his life other than the tree
which is why he created the tree and her
place in the story was a very sad one
hell I like Toby Kebbell in this movie
Toby Kebbell xin it briefly not for long
Toby Kebbell really is the only element
to this movie that has the quips I don't
want to say quips real I think that's
the wrong word for it it's very human
moments of humor where he just kind of
drops these little nuggets here and
there and I thought he was a great
element in here really what a monster
calls is is a movie about letting go or
at least accepting your reality this is
one of those movies while you're
watching it you're on the fringe you
look I enjoy it but I don't know
how much and the way the movie wraps up
in the end is what gives the movie its
beauty and gravity one thing I need to
address right now this is not a movie
for kids and I saw the trailer I was
like oh this kid gets a friend that's
awesome that's great imaginary friends
good for kids right not really not that
the movies bad for kids it just deals
with issues that kids are really
detached from if you're thinking like
you know five-year-olds it's not a movie
for five-year-olds this is a movie for a
teenager like 13 on I'm just saying in
terms of the development of children
I feel like teenagers on will actually
get the concepts this movie deals with
little kids will be like why isn't group
beating up the bullies I mean where's
rocket yeah let's watch Groot beat up
the bullies but in terms of the movie's
themes and how it deals with it and the
stories that the tree gives in the tree
and so I thought everything really came
together well in here I enjoyed a
monster calls a lot it's a beautiful
movie with a really heavy message I will
say for me a monster calls is worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray
the monster Groot and tribute at the end
I'd love to book dude get that
collaboration going I Cal I'd pay for
that bombshell of imagination right guys
so a monster calls have you seen it what
did you think about it Matt says many of
you did not see it or what's your
favorite story of imagination and
reality you know those stories where
it's like it's imagination or is it
don't know whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]